[موسيقى]
وزير الدفاع الصيني الجديد عهد قد ينبئ
بتوترات مع الولايات المتحده
صحيح انه يطابق الصفات المفترضه للحزب
الشيوعي الصيني وحظي بموافقه اعلى هيئه
تشريعيه في الصين لكنه مدرج في قائمه
العقوبه الامريكيه منذ عام 2018
حيث تتهمه واشنطن بالتعاون العسكري مع
موسكو حينما كان يتراس مديريه الاسلحه
علما بانه شغل منصب رئيس قسم تطوير
المعدات وقاد قوه الدعم الاستراتيجي للجيش
الصيني وامضى ثلاثه عقود من الزمن في مركز
شيت شانغ لاطلاق الاقمار الصناعيه ما يعني
ان صعود ليشانغو يعكس تطورا غير مسبوق
لمؤسسه الفضاء
اذ ستواصل بكين منح الاولويه للفضاء في
اجنده ولايه شيجين بنج الثالثه وسيمثل
وجود وزير الدفاع الجديد عمل المحفزا
باستحداث تكنولوجيات قتاليه ينافس بها
امريكا